in 13 days a lot of people in the
country are talking about this we want
you to talk about it too on November
20th Rodney Reed remember that name he's
scheduled to be executed in Texas he was
convicted of raping and killing 19 year
old Stacey Stites back in 1996 Reed says
they were in a consensual relationship
and people have cooperated that story
and he maintains his innocence in the
meantime her fiance a police officer
allegedly confessed to another inmate
when he was in prison for an unrelated
crime but he has since retracted that
confession celebrities and lawmakers
have called for the conviction to be
overturned citing this new witness
testimony so far more than two million
people have signed an online petition to
stop his execution I first saw this this
story on dr. Phil dr. Phil had gone to
the prison to interview that's where I
first and now I see more and more people
are talking about it but because there
is so much conflicting testimony at the
very least there should be a stay of the
execution mind me Oprah Anthony Reagan
who spent which was another book I was
on here for talking about mr. Spence mr.
Hinton spent 30 years in on death row
for a crime he did not commit I think at
least the governor has to pause and look
at the 2 million people who have signed
a petition us two million voices saying
listen to us something's off here
something needs to be done watching yeah
hello I think this is this is a sign
you're supposed to at least not execute
but at least take them take a break and
in the law rather let 10 guilty people
free than kill one innocent man one of
the things that Anthony Hinton says in
his book the Sun does shine he actually
lists all the people who are on death
row and so many of them a great
percentage are on there for something a
crime and a lot of them are people have
cover a lot of them are people of color
and it's not so much that celebrities
are bringing attention to the story but
there are a lot of people who are not
celebrities who are saying like you said
you know the 2 million people who sign
that petition well and the evidence
itself is very compelling so right